CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
Mr. Haqqani--
Sirajuddin Haqqani,
welcome to the program.
SIRAJUDDIN HAQQANI:
[non-english speech]
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR: Now,
you have only recently
shown yourself publicly.
Here, it was at a police
passing out parade.
This is your first
proper interview.
Why now?
SIRAJUDDIN HAQQANI:
[non-english]
INTERPRETER: Based on
the current necessity,
and because of this necessity,
the local and international
community had concerns.
Based on the
concerns that existed
on local and
international levels
about a number of individuals
who do not want to be blamed
for implementing
the commitments that
have been made with the
international community.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
The only thing we really
know about your thoughts
now is something
you wrote for "The New York
Times" back a couple of years
ago at the beginning
of negotiations
with the Trump administration.
You wrote then that
"I'm confident."
And you said, "once this
territory is liberated,
we together will find a way
to build an Islamic system
in which all Afghans
have equal rights, where
the rights of women that
are granted by Islam,
from the right to education
to the right to work,
are protected, and
where merit is the basis
for equal opportunity."
I want to know whether
you still believe that.
SIRAJUDDIN HAQQANI:
[non-english speech]
INTERPRETER: The commitments
that have been made--
the situation at the time
was a situation of war.
The opposing parties
have provided
a very bad picture
and definition
of our administration.
We wanted to take over the
government by peaceful means.
And the former government,
with the assistance
of some other circles,
sabotaged our particular plan
or program, the
transfer of power
under military conditions.
Currently, there are a large
amount of rumors and hearsay.
And for this reason,
the strong decision
is under way so that we can
implement the commitments that
have been made by us within
an environment of trust
so that we can implement
those commitments.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
Many times I
have spoken occasionally
to Taliban leaders,
even back in the 1990s.
And they told me
something similar,
that it will take time.
And yet it never happened.
Do you believe that young
girls, secondary school
girls will be allowed to go
to school here in Afghanistan?
SIRAJUDDIN HAQQANI:
[non-english speech]
INTERPRETER: I would like to
provide some clarification.
There is no one who opposes
education for women.
And already, girls are allowed
to go to school up to grade 6
and above that grade.
The work is continuing
on a mechanism.
You may have heard that this
is not opposed at the level
of leadership or the cabinet.
But the issue has been
postponed until further notice.
In the declaration provided
by the Ministry of Education,
there were some shortcoming
within the preparation
that were ongoing.
Work is ongoing on those issues.
Through this interview
and news channel,
I am assuring that
there is no one
opposed to education,
only that work
has started on the mechanism.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
Could you tell us when
you think that will happen?
I know there has been a
big meeting in Kandahar
with your Supreme
Leader Mr. Akhunzada.
Can you tell me whether
any decisions were
made over this past few days?
SIRAJUDDIN HAQQANI:
[non-english speech]
INTERPRETER: What
I am saying to you
is that very soon you
will hear very good news
about this issue, God willing.
We will specify the time.
On the arrangement that has
been provided by the leadership,
work is ongoing on that.
And you will hear
very good news soon.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
Can I ask you--
I don't know whether
you have any daughters.
But do you favor your daughters
going to secondary school?
SIRAJUDDIN HAQQANI:
[non-english speech]
INTERPRETER: We all believe
that education has been created
as a blessing from
God, which has
been made essential
to both men and women.
As I mentioned earlier, there is
no one is opposed to education.
The problem is education
based on the Afghan way
of thinking, and
understanding the culture
aspect of Afghanistan.
There is an issue of
making arrangement
of Islamic rules and principle.
On a broader level,
the situation
that exists in Afghanistan
concerning the issue of hijab,
because if someone
is giving away
their daughters or sisters, they
do that based on total trust.
We must establish the
conditions so that we can ensure
their honor and security.
We are acting to ensure this.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
I'm going to come
back to this in a minute.
But first, I want to ask
you about the United States
because many people
in the United States
are obviously interested.
Now, you have signs
and slogans that I've
seen painted on the
walls, some of them
touting defeating
the United States.
Some of them say that you are
by the people, of the people.
About America-- do you consider
America still to be your enemy?
SIRAJUDDIN HAQQANI:
[non-english speech]
INTERPRETER: I would like to
make a small clarification.
The period of the last
20 years was a situation
of defensive fighting and war.
When the agreement
was made in Doha,
we decided that we would
not be talking about this.
In the future, we
would like to have
good relations with
the United States
and the international
community based
on rules and principles that
exist in the rest of the world.
And based on that
arrangement, we
have made commitment with them.
And currently, we do not
look at them as enemies.
But based on their conduct,
the Afghans have reservations
about their intentions.
From our side, the freedom
of the country and struggling
for the country's defense is a
legitimate right in accordance
with the international rules.
Currently, we do not
look at them as enemies.
And we have, time and again,
spoken about diplomacy.
We are committed to
the Doha agreement.
Like the rest of the
world, we want relations
with them based on principles
and diplomatic norms
that they establish
with us, and that they
don't go back on that.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
We'll get to some
of those reasons in a moment.
But I do have to ask you, Mr.
Haqqani, because you know very
well that you are under
personal sanctions
by the United States,
which also has
a multimillion-dollar
bounty on your head.
This is what a top
Western official
told me just before I got here.
He said, "We're in a new world.
The guy"-- that's you--
"has a huge amount of
American blood on his hands.
He's got in the
Taliban the tightest
ties to extremist movements.
He was also one of
the first to put women
back to work in his ministry.
We have seen his ministry
take promising steps
to contain terrorism.
To call it a paradox
is an understatement.
This is not just my opinion.
It's the opinion of
every single envoy
who works on these issues."
So on the one hand, they
believe you're a terrorist,
I'm sorry to say. that's
they who say that.
On the other hand, they
think they can work with you.
What do you say to that?
SIRAJUDDIN HAQQANI:
[non-english speech]
INTERPRETER: I would say
that this is a judgment
that they should make.
I have mentioned this
before, that they
have fought us intensely.
And in order to defend
the country and ourselves,
our response was the same.
But the commitment and
the form of governance,
in order to create
secure Afghanistan,
we sent a positive
message to the world
and sent a positive
message to our nation,
while the previous situation
had concealed our real picture.
And currently, praise God,
under the conditions of freedom,
our conduct is being
revealed gradually
to the international community.
And also, this has been
revealed to certain circles
within the country who are
thinking negatively about us.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
One of the key pledges
you made to the United States
was that Afghanistan would
never again be used as
a basis for terrorism
against the US or its allies.
Do you-- are you still
committed to that?
And how do you explain,
in recent months,
there have been attacks here,
people saying that they belong
to ISIS, ISIS-K, increasingly
bold attacks on, you know,
on education centers,
even on mosques, on a bus,
even on a school.
Some 100 or so people
have been killed
in recent weeks and months.
I mean, that doesn't look
like a very secure situation.
SIRAJUDDIN HAQQANI:
[non-english speech]
INTERPRETER: The commitments
that we have made, if you think
about it, during the 14 months
after Doha, even though there
were a large number of
transgressions continuing
from the opposing
side against us,
our leadership was
making recommendations
to us repeatedly that we should
stick to our commitment as well
as the fact that until
the liberation of Kabul,
we were making effort
to uphold our commitment
and come to power
through peaceful means.
Here, we have internal threats.
And some are deliberately
elevating the threats
to portray them as a cause
of concern for the nation
and for the
international community.
There can be threats to the
rest of the world that are
orchestrated by a government.
But we would like to strongly
reassure the rest of the world
that our land will not be
used as a threat to anyone.